here to present the screenplay Awards
our two gentlemen last performed for
Oscar twenty-seven years ago I'm pleased
and very proud to say that I've known
them both all my life one perhaps a
little bit longer mr. Burt Lancaster mr.
Kirk Douglas
we nominated this year go you haven't
been either Kirk congratulation great
nothing it beating for a great not to be
one who said they make such like
and anyone who says it's nothing's just
a flower go fellas who want it just
can't get a job
we'll take our chances
it's great not to be nominated brave not
to be nominated
birth tell me who are those kids child
actors obviously can you seriously BRR
can you believe we were ever that age
I can't believe on this one gentlemen
please you know I knew he was gonna do
so well I'd have been much nicer to him
when he was little it's too late
the five nominated best screenplays
written directly for the screen testify
to the imagination and invention of the
screenwriter they deal with life on both
sides of the law
life on the East Coast life on the west
and at one point in between life on the
land and love under the sea
they are Beverly Hills cup screenplay by
Daniel Petrie jr. story by Danilo Bach
and Daniel Petrie jr. Broadway Danny
Rose written by Woody Allen
and nor take screenplay by Gregory Nava
and out of Thomas
places in the heart written by Robert
Becker
glad screenplay by lo against Babylon
Mandel and Bruce J Friedman screen story
by Bruce J Friedman based on a story by
Brian Grazer
and it's written that the winner is the
winner is Robert Benton four places in a
heart
there are great many people to thank and
not much time I would like to thank mr.
john malkovich lindsay crouse mr. Danny
Glover sir ed Harris amy madigan Yankton
Hatton Jenny James I would especially
like to thank Sally Field without her
genius and her courage I would not be
standing here like IOD Greta dad debt of
gratitude to Carol Littleton to Nestor
almond gross and most of all to arlene
Donovan I would also like to thank mr.
Cohn and all the people that Tristar
David Victor Gary and Doug Sydney
[ __ ] and to mostly to my family and
here and in Waxahachie and exit into the
people of attach thank you very much
five nominees for Best Screenplay based
on material from another medium showed
no less boldness in the variety of
subjects they tackled from a man who was
a musical genius to one who was raised
by beasts from colonialism to racist to
the human devastation of war Amadeus
screenplay by Peter Shaffer
greystoke The Legend of Tarzan lord of
the Apes screaming buzzing and Michael
Austin The Killing Fields screenplay by
Bruce Robinson a Passage to India
screenplay by David Lee
soldiers story screenplay by Charles
fuller
and the winner is Peter Shaffer for
Amadeo
I'd like to thank the Academy for this
distinguished present I know my
colleagues and there are so many of them
attached to this film you'll forgive me
tonight if I mention anyone named that
of Milosh Foreman mr. Foreman as I'm
sure you know is a remarkable and
distinguished screenwriter in his own
right as well as a remarkable and
distinguished director and his
contribution to the transference of my
play to the screen was gigantic we both
decided that music would be the center
of the film and my great pleasure is
that Mozart has now reached millions and
millions of people who had not heard him
before thank you very much
you